biggest advertising group WPP has
lowered its growth forecast for the
third time this year let's speak to its
founder and chief executive Sir Martin
Sorrell who was in New York Martin good
to see you no WPP this is for decades of
listening to balot but larger ISM
bookies the law reason beware we're a
broad Church on this show Martin as you
know I mean what's to blame for this
downturn in in that spending well we're
seeing a lot of pressure
the question is Ian frankly where is it
coming from is it coming from Facebook
and Google I think the answer's no
because we invest our media division
invest very heavily in Google and
Facebook to the tune of about seven
billion dollars a year and it's probably
our number one and number three media
destination for investment so it's not
that is it because consultants are
eating our lunch in in terms of digital
consulting activities we think now if
you look at the the record this for the
first nine months of the year in terms
of our competition against them we do
pretty well we win on a two-to-one basis
and by value probably even stronger than
that about four to one so it doesn't
appear to be that it could be that
consultants are going to our clients to
the CEOs of clients are saying you're
spending too much generally not just on
marketing but generally reduce your cost
and we'll get paid on a percentage of
what we save I think that's part of it
and last but not least and probably and
the most important point these pools of
capital in a low-interest cost
environment built around activist
investors or zero based budgeting
companies such as 3G such as Reckitt
Benckiser or Cote are putting a lot of
pressure particular on packaged goods
companies to cut their costs and their
reaction is to cut their variable
marketing costs we think it's an
investment not a cost but the fact of
life is there's a tremendous amount of
pressure particularly in the packaged
goods sector which accounts for about a
third of our revenues yeah that's right
as you say the the likes of Unilever
Nestle all under immense pressure right
now from activist investors do you see
that moving away anytime soon that
pressure well it depends on what happens
to interest rates you're probably as
much of an expert
anybody on this and you probably would
would agree that interest rates over
time will probably rise but will they go
back to where they were pre layman
that's pre 2008 probably not so the
world we face is a low growth world
three to four percent growth low
inflation limited pricing power and
therefore clients are focused very much
on cost so in that environment we have
to revamp our offer we have to make it
much more integrative for our clients so
it's seamless that we're managing 1pl
instead of a multiplicity and we're
focus very much on efficiency as well as
better work effective work secondly if
co could focus on the fast growth
markets the the Asian the Latin America
in the African Middle East and the
central Eastern European markets because
that's when the next billion consumers
will come and then last but not least
digital and data digital is already 40
percent of our business against the
worldwide weighting of about 30 percent
it probably will permeate everything we
do them there's still significant growth
there and last but not least data is
about 25 percent of our business and
linking data to our offer is critically
important so those four things
integration or horizontality as we call
it fast growth markets digital and data
a key to our future motto were very
short on time here but I just want to
ask you've said in the past that
companies like Google and Facebook and
not just social media platforms their
media companies and should be treated as
such you think they should be regulating
like media companies I mean if we allow
false news fake news on our Channel
we're told off by the regulator should
they be similarly regulated well you're
raising a very big emotional issue
particularly from where you sit in and
what you represent but having having
crossed that Rubicon I would say well I
have not much of a truck for Steve
Bannon but before he left the White
House what he did say is Google and
Facebook are utilities and they should
be regulated as such we've seen in the
EU already some regulation I think there
are two more decisions to come down from
the Director General vest ago so I think
this whole issue of regulation of these
very powerful technologically based
platforms not
like it's the fearsome five-year it's
Apple and Amazon and Facebook and Google
all of them plus the two Chinese
fearsome five make it fearsome seven the
Seven Sisters I guess of this movie that
I'm afraid Alibaba and ten and ten cent
are awful also powerful too